I know when to welcome to this video FM
montalais August opponent we're going to
play nice playing this one can I do
something else there are only nokia
alternatives are really not good oh the
belgrade that you don't see often at all
[Music]
that's one of the good lines against it
we should be seven is good even getting
take on your form wow I don't really
remember what is played down you never
get it on the board
maybe I could have taken could have
taken on d5 but just just normal moves I
find him maybe you can try night be
three but should be six and t6 the only
thing that looks somewhat interesting
[Music]
well maybe I should have avoided that
looks a little bit a little bit awkward
Bishop f3
that's prolly probably equal ish but
against the Belgrade you actually want
more than equal ish and yeah so what's
the deal Bishop g4 is one move a couple
of things possible but this is not bad
cannot take the five because it should
be too so probably the capture both will
happen yeah now there are a couple of
things here Queen to f6 stuff on f2
yeah normals no nothing fancy so I one
directly to him it looks a bit loose
this move
should be possible though and so I
cannot take on f 2 is what you are
saying here why why can I not take them
because of the pin self pen or maybe
I don't know take it take it 94 maybe
yeah this this I only saw at the latest
moment and that could have this may be
too late okay so if i take their queen
g6 huh
it was stuff was really really really
really dumb check that was dumb
so maybe not totally simple but of
course them that's not what you want and
then overlooking simple things really
simple things if I cookie six years by
the way what is he doing then Queen f4
mmm no continuation like I want to see
first how he if he if he can convert
this isn't isn't even though that easy
he's got three isolated points and not
particularly great piece coordination
and currently I'm threatening group d
aid which is not a big threat maybe
[Music]
threatens rooty for which is not very
subtle but still
[Music]
yeah this is not easy at all for what
naughty 0 got no coordination absolutely
absolutely no coordination
I don't know what he wants to watch what
you eat place he actually is really not
easy to find a move it cannot move the
a1 look night is pinned it's pretty
awkward I would have considered to link
the King I think but yeah again that
wasn't easy so okay one may be trying to
use the pin time warning check
yeah I don't actually want to take onda
for now maybe I have to do that hash
should shouldn't have done that for the
dead end game that end game was actually
already quite comfortable no let's not
do that 20 seconds this is the main
thing of the position check check check
right position is just a draw that's
okay check let's set a draw check no
it's not a draw check check check white
forfeits on time okay that was not
really deserved not really a draw would
be normal position wise but
yeah so pretty weird stuff I probably
made some mistakes in the move water
here in the opening because well yeah
this is this is a borderline opening we
have black young can play for an
advantage but maybe I should just take
the corn I was just kind of thinking
okay I don't take anything I just
develop but I really don't see what the
compensation is and neither does the
engine I mean it says 0.2 but place III
what kind of compensation as that yeah
but ok that it cannot be bad but
probably my move all that sucks I should
probably play um play some B 6 earlier
this is a little bit awkward I think I'm
okay but it was a bit awkward so here
yeah yeah and this is probably I just
run at 94 check yeah it's funny and that
it isn't King age to a stronger hey oh
wow okay and this isn't that clear right
yeah I was kind of thinking the same but
this is of course very strong and all my
book is hanging and mine either saying
yeah I can see I'm just lost boo yeah
Tim yeah can the engine give slight
disadvantage but this is extremely
difficult to play because you have no
coordination whatsoever yeah I wanted to
play for an advantage but he couldn't
quite make it work this okay yeah i was
thinking of those tricks here with rook
you forward this is of course nonsense
here here I'm probably losing
and I had to go back and lost time so I
got into this drone ending which then by
some miracle i won ok guys thanks for
watching